hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast antha an operating system for
seamlessly linking experimental design
and lab automation I am Judy Aurora
black boots and all be your moderator
for today's event we're delighted to
bring this educational web seminar
presented by lab groups and sponsored by
PerkinElmer PerkinElmer is a global
leader focused on improving the health
and safety of people and the environment
its dedicated team of 7700 employees
worldwide are passionate about providing
customers with an unmatched experience
as they help solve critical issues in
human and environmental health the
company's innovative detection imaging
informatics and service capabilities the
line with deep market knowledge and
expertise helps customers gain greater
insight into their science to better
protect our environment our food supply
and health of our family for more
information please visit www Kirkconnell
mercom we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to the Interactive's
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green chewing a button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the report button at the top right of
your presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Soren a button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker Sean Ward founder and
chief technology officer syntace limited
sean is a serial entrepreneur for
sending music industry was relatable and
currently in synthetic biology with
synthase where he is the architect and
driving force behind Ansah high level
language and operating system for
working with biology before founding
extent based sean was a research
associate in bioinformatics at
University College London where he
conducted research into protein folding
in structure prediction and gene coding
a relatable Shawn invented audio
fingerprinting which was used by major
peer to peer companies such as Napster
sean is also an advisor on synthetic
biology to the biotechnology and
Biological Sciences Research Council and
ace in bio leaps fellow I will now turn
it over to Sean Ward for his
presentation thank you Judy as she
mentioned I'm a synthetic biologist
which means I take a slightly different
perspective about how to understand
biology mostly it means that I cheat
because I get to make changes to an
organism and try to understand what that
change does by empirically that were
dating through a variety of different
essay protocols and a different number
technologies what it actually does and
that's key because let's be frank
working with biology is hard
at its root working with biotechnology
takes too long costs too much and fails
too often and that's a problem that
faces every single application that we
have with biology Viet how we can
develop a new drug how we can develop a
new industrial biotechnology
manufacturing process or how you can
bring new crop traits to market in Ag
science at the heart of it is the fact
that of course you're dealing with
complexity I mean the number of
interacting factors you encounter we
start talking about writing a genome is
exponential not to mention all the end
other interactions to take place with
the environment with a feedstock
you
we have a brief technological
culty on stay with us we will repair it
immediately and Sean Ward will be right
back with us so just bear with us for
just a moment
apologies we had a minor technical
difficulty there are you able to hear me
again yes we are okay excellent so we
just discovered the third problem in
action which is that even complex
systems like phones have traceability
issues at times you know the heart is
that everything in biology is context
dependent if you transplant a gene say
for the production of an industrial
enzyme from one organism to another
you're also transplanting what is the
entire machinery used to both produce
Trent to fold and potentially
post-translationally modify that protein
and it may completely alter the toxicity
the function and even the fundamental
ability to have any useful product from
that action now I'm picking these sorts
of high-order interactions that exist
between the context dependence of
biological function is hard even in the
best of times but the problem is that we
compound that with the problem that our
base working practices themselves don't
give us definitive understandings of
what's going on post file as you did
quite a damning report back in January
when looking at the fundamental research
practices call it the working practices
with which we work with biology and with
which we are ultimately trying to infer
our conclusions we're themselves
grounded in sand out of 441 randomly
selected publications only one of them
was actually even theoretically
reproducible I have enough information
contained within the methods section the
third party could do that work what it
fundamentally is showing is that in
biology we have a real problem with the
transfer of tacit knowledge the ability
to effectively describe how it is that
we actually do our work and without the
ability to describe how we work well the
ability to understand whether or not any
particular result was a product of that
methodism of collecting the information
about it or whether or not it was
actually a result of the biology that
you were investigating is an extremely
unclear situation and that's why major
reproducibility studies and cancer
therapeutics by bear and am
have shown that twenty-five percent and
eleven percent of actual beliefs about
what's going on in cancer systems were
actually reproducible by third parties
which again there's little wonder why
that's the case when our basic lab
practices themselves will vary from
person to person within the same lab let
alone between different institutions
ultimately what that means is that we're
trying to work on incredibly complex
systems when we don't even necessarily
know whether the outcomes that we're
looking at we're coming from the biology
or simply the practices with which we're
engaging with it in fact it's why when
you look at the productivity our ability
to effectively work with biology there's
a negative exponential that's gone back
for the last 65 years in fact it has
named eros law and no other field
operates with this sort of negative
productivity effect across the years now
what that means is that inflation
adjusted every 18 months it doubles in
the cost to bring a drug to market now
that is of course a confounded problem
with regulation and of course the fact
that you might say many of the
low-hanging results in biology in terms
of drug indications have already been
collected but you encounter similar
challenges when working with biology and
other contexts in industrial
biotechnology it still takes on average
seven years to bring an industrial
process to the commercial scale and
north of a hundred million dollars worth
of investment and in ag science you're
talking about over a decade and on
average you know three hundred million
dollars to bring a crop trade to market
in both of those cases it's the inherent
complexity of the biological systems
that we're dealing with that are our
fundamental limitations now when people
think about dealing with complex systems
and Exponential's the most classic one
is Moore's Law from the semiconductor
industry essentially that's the fact
that the number of transistors we can
put into a processor has doubled every
18 months he said the inversion of what
has been the productivity curve in the
pharma industry now that's an entire
stair-step of various innovations it's
led to it
but it was a change that happened in the
early 1980s the introduction of
electronic design automation and in
particular high-level languages VHDL and
verilog which was the single most
important transformation in the course
of semiconductors it meant that all of a
sudden be still only thirty thousand
semiconductor designers that were on the
planet could have all of a sudden an
entire tool stack with which they could
engage this exponentially increasing
problem of how do you design a chip
where you're going to have to deal with
twice the number of moving pieces that
he did in the previous 18 months and it
also meant that that tool stack could
transition the way that we fundamentally
worked with semiconductors from in the
early 1960s our first planar integrated
circuits that were entirely designed on
a piece of paper designed with a human
mind laid out by hand and ultimately
found by hand to the modern processes
today at a place like Intel where
billions of transistors are designed
around using an entire tool stack that
in the pros of the industry compiles the
silicon because these design tools talk
directly to the hardware that ultimately
is creating the physical objects that
ultimately become these products so
recognizing that we needed to be able to
start to move up this ladder to have a
tool stack that allows us to engage with
the complexities of working with biology
at synthase we created alpha which is
very much like the HDL and verilog a
language for describing what you are
physically trying to produce what is the
experiment that you're trying to conduct
and it's the start of what we hope will
be the entire design tool stack that
ultimately will let us address grand
challenges like how do you engineer an
entire genome how do we more
cost-effectively produce drugs how do we
have bio manufacturing processes that
help lead us off of oil now wire
language is so important for
productivity the frank reality is
because there a way to encapsulate and
manage complexity the average
professional computer program are still
only produces 10,000 lines of fully
debugged fully documented code per year
that's remained the same since
1960s however clearly what we do with
information technology has progressed
rapidly since then you can build a you
know an iphone app visually in the
course of days today and that's because
instead of describing all the low-level
details associated with you know
programming instruments telling it how
to move bits around in registers the
processor like you do an assembler we
instead have high-level languages like
Python which allow us to express the
intent behind our actions such as that
we want to print hello world to the
screen compilers are also an important
piece of this tool stack there what
helps translate a language and check the
semantics it's how you can do the
equivalent of a grammar check and a
spellcheck atop what you have written it
within a language and it helps to catch
many of the mistakes that can be caught
automatically and so empowers a user to
be able to be more effective to help
debug the thought processes that are
represented within their language so in
the same way antha exists as two
languages one for describing workflows
as a composition of elements these
elements themselves are then defined
textually as reusable and executable
working practices think things like the
way you can stitch DNA together or
transformation protocols or assay
procedures in turn these definitions of
what you are trying to conduct as a
biological experiment are made
executable by the ampa operating system
this talks to various pieces of
laboratory equipment through drivers and
drives the physical execution of your
experiment and importantly it also deals
with translation between environments so
the same protocol can be written for as
an example a gilson pipette max or for a
perkin-elmer Janis g3 it also deals with
many of the logistical problems that you
encounter when planning designing and
executing an experiment many respects
this is like enterprise resource
planning software brought forward into
the laboratory dealing with your
problems around scheduling about whether
or not you have the right reagents to be
able to conduct this experiment and
integrating all of the information
outputs that come from your experiment
now let's get a little bit more concrete
about what we're talking about here four
elements and why systematically looking
at your basic working practices is so
important so as a synthetic biologist if
I can't make the DNA constructs the
interventions into the genome of an
organism with which I'm trying to work
well I'm kind of sunk it's the bread and
butter that allows me to unlock the
entire range of genetic interventions
that I'm trying to engineer to
ultimately understand their function or
effect on the organism in our case we
use a variance of an assembly protocol
based on type 2s remote cutting
restriction enzymes what that
essentially means is that the
recognition site is distant from where
the cut is made within DNA and that
means that you can essentially define a
pure series of overhangs so that after
the cut is made the reactor ignition
site is no longer within the region that
has been cut out this means that you're
able to very quickly assemble complex
constructs where the different component
pieces within your entire construct can
be modularly swapped around or replaced
by alternates with in any particular
slot these remote cuts then can in a
single pot reaction be mixed together
with ligase and because you have these
overlaps that are compatible they will
only assemble in one direction the net
result of this is that you have a very
simple protocol for being able to
assemble potentially combinatorial
numbers of parts the other piece though
is you can start to look at a practice
like this and investigate what it is
that makes it successful in our case
like many originally academically derive
technologies it would work about half
the time yielding of proper colony I
mean anyone who's worked in a wet lab
has have that sole shaking experience of
walking in to check your plate and
finding out that there's nothing on it
so you definitely want that to be a high
figure but unfortunately it wasn't
necessarily going to be a good sign just
have a colonies because half the time
you would end up with the wrong
construct as well however it turns out
that if you systematically investigate
all
the low-level details of a working
practice like say stitching together DNA
it's possible to find a part of the
design space optimizing things like
which enzyme you're utilizing your
concentrations of DNA the temperature
that you run it with and whether or not
many of the standard practices that we
take for granted in the laboratory like
as an example that you may have to heat
shock your cell lines to do the
transformation end up being wrong and
finding the right way of running this
means that you can build a protocol that
works all of a sudden one hundred
percent of the time with colonies and
ninety-nine percent of them are the
correct construct so you transformed
yourself from a position where your lab
practice was an unreliable and artisanal
operation where you were bottlenecked
heavily by chasing down your constructs
that didn't assemble to it being
something that could be performed by any
person and allows you to now build
thousands of Pacific interventions at
once and having done so you can now
record it in antha now as I mentioned
antha is a language for describing these
executable working practices so in this
case construct assembly consists of
saying that you're going to mix into an
output plate a series of samples
including genetic parts and enzymes and
that you're following that by incubating
at two different temperatures this is
something that even if you perhaps
haven't written code before you should
be able to read and understand but more
importantly by representing a working
practice in this form you have something
that can be translated into a variety of
environments in this case that
ultimately means various liquid handlers
also this systematic structuring and
thinking through about what parts of a
protocol were actually important means
that you can go from much more
complicated protocols such as Gibson
assembly or even Golden Gate which
require the use of PCR as part of the
amplification process that don't allow
part reuse because they require things
like a specific primer for an assembly
that require complex integrated work
cells that have things on deck like say
purification or that require thermal
cycling and it ultimately means
you can have a much simpler and more
robust lab process and protocol which
means that you can translate for a
comparable execution into a whole
variety of manufacturers environments
including hardware from sie bo gilson
and I'm happy to announce perkin-elmer
with their Jana's platform now this sort
of protocol optimization isn't limited
to simplifying something like construct
assembly it's just as important to be
able to systematically investigate what
are the factors that are driving
successful execution of assay protocols
so as an example an experimental design
such as a definitive screen can be used
to simultaneously improve the signal to
noise and also understand what are the
major drivers of success rate of
something like immunoassay and to be
clear the signals noise on your essay is
the fundamental bottleneck on your
ability to draw insight and ultimately
definitive conclusions about what's
going on in a complex biological system
and of course if you don't model the
complexity that drives the things like
the successful signals noise of an assay
you may find that instead of being able
to have optimized it you're sitting
right on an edge and you can't even
truthfully trust the outcomes that came
from your essay and as I mentioned the
nice thing about having transmitting it
this way is that it will translate from
extremely capable instruments that can
run complex integrated processes on
themselves such as the Janus all the way
through to simple actions like a gilson
pipette Max or even manual workflows so
where do we see are the changes that
have to be made in how we work with
biology for us it starts by a robust
characterization of our inherently
practices if you don't have reliable
working practices if you can't transform
your cell lines if you can't effectively
make genetic interventions if your
assays have four signal to noise well
you basically cannot draw definitive
conclusions also if your fundamental lab
practices are unsound automation is
hobble it's not an asset if only
twenty-five percent of your constructs
are
that's fully assembled and you now try
to make thousands using automation well
then you've just created hundreds of
problems for yourself on the other hand
if your fundamental working practices
are reliable and robust automation is a
force multiplier it means that all of a
sudden you have the potential to
flexibly execute complex experiments
that give you a sufficient experimental
bandwidth you can properly apply
multifactorial experimentation unpick
definitively what's going on in a
biological system and of course being
able to build successful models about
what is going on in these biological
systems means that you can properly
start to engineer with biology which is
a critical bottleneck in our ability to
apply it in areas such as industrial
biotechnology to be clear I'm not
speaking about this just for principles
I'm speaking about the lessons that
we've already learned it's in base this
is the transformation we've made
ourselves and which antha and our anti
operating system was the linchpin to
being able to make this transformation
so how does all this work well as I
mentioned at the top it's about having a
robust model of what is the experiment
you're trying to conduct so Anthony
allows you to define the flow of
information and physical objects between
these elements so taking a standard sort
of synthetic biology workflow that means
things like planning what construct
you're trying to make checking whether
or not you have to synthesize DNA or
retrieve parts out of your freezer
before then means stitching together
that DNA transforming a cell line
growing it up and then validating that
you've successfully made the correct
constructs the elements themselves are
then a robust way of describing any one
of those unit operations this is a
programming language which is based on
an extension of the go language from
Google so you can do any computational
workflow you want including complex
bioinformatics pipelines or complex
modeling tools right within these
elements but it importantly extends it
into describing actions in the physical
world so
elements start by defining what do they
depend on this can be as an example
specific pieces of equipment such as
liquid handling or different pieces of
analytic kits such as a plate reader
this can also be a robust definition of
what is the specific other working
practice that this depends upon such as
the repository URL on github of another
anti element there's no anantha
searching for the methods section of a
paper from 1976 next major section is
the parameters and data which defines
all of the information flow in and out
of an antha element it has a strong type
system so antha understands the
difference between a volume and a
temperature and whether or not you're
expressing microliters or leaders or
peaker leaders this is important because
this is the interface for this working
practice in essence it's what are the
variables that you may need to optimize
inputs and outputs is similarly a type
system over the physical objects that
are coming in and are produced by an
element so it knows the difference
between a genetic construct in a cell
line and thus is able to tell you what
working practices can be compatibly
linked together the requirements section
allows you to do input testing so
something like a construct assembly
protocol is often going to be dependent
upon the types of inputs that you're
running so for example you can make sure
that you don't have within the coding
region that you're trying to stitch
together any restriction enzyme sites
that are going to be in conflict with
the restriction enzymes are utilized in
that construct assembly protocol now the
heart of an ant element is the steps
block whether you're describing what you
do to aunt in the context of a single
sample going through the system now
that's because the complexity of
describing how you manage thousands of
simultaneous threads of an experiment
it's hard for professional programmers
and it's an incredibly difficult problem
to schedule and map it all down to
things like individual plates and when
they are being moved as such you always
write from the standpoint of a single
thread of execution a single sample and
you have no information or access to
information about the other samples that
are being processed
however there's certain classes of
protocols like an assay where you do
have dependence on other samples that
are being used in the system such as
needing to be able to describe that
there's a control curve attached with an
SI the setup block and then ultimately
the analysis block enables you to pierce
that veil and define these dependencies
in a very structured way so the system
has the degrees of freedom it needs to
ultimately optimize the execution of
your experiment and you have a
simplicity of expression that keeps what
you have to use to describe ultimately
the complex execution of thousands of
experiments at once as a simple process
lastly the validation section enables
you to validate that you've actually
executed this element successfully
unfortunately when we're doing
experimental biology it's often
extremely expensive and so catching that
we've made a mistake early if key to
being able to reduce that downstream
cost now unfortunately again in biology
often finding out what is the current
state of a biological system is
destructive and so you can tag tests
that are either destructive or non
destructive it can be optionally
performed while you're conducting these
experiments so that you have inline QC
as part of your experimental workflow a
good example of a non-destructive test
would be something like looking at the
r-squared value of your control curve on
your essay to determine whether or not
it appears to have been executed
correctly so when it comes to actually
working with antha it starts with sample
management if you don't know what all
the physical objects are in your lap
what containers they're stored within
and what is the protons of every thing
within those containers and of course
where those things are physically
located you can't of course properly
describe the flow of samples and the
flow of information to a workflow the
next major step about working with antha
is to define what's the experimental
workflow that you want to run of course
that's easiest to do by showing you
before you can run an experiment it's
important to actually define what
experiment
planning to conduct antha provides
repositories of your elements and
workflows that can be shared both on an
individual or organizational basis
editing a workflow is completely visual
and are able to drag and drop new
elements out of your libraries into it
you can see here that every input and
output of an element is visually coded
as information flow or physical object
flow and can be wired directly up
between elements you also see a
collection of unfulfilled inputs passing
to the left these are what are needed to
actually launch a workflow you can of
course dive right into the code level of
an individual element so if you decide
you need to make a change in a working
practice that can all be done completely
in your web browser while defining this
saving elements is all version
controlled under the hood this is based
on git
so having defined a workflow to be able
to actually execute it successfully then
you need to pass in what are all the
parameters that have been defined as
empty within the workflow and again that
means you can build visual tools to help
you assist the assistant and planning
reasoning about and executing your
experiment again the easiest way is to
show that as mentioned previously to run
an anthro workflow you need to satisfy
all of the inputs in many cases this can
be done by importing an input file from
another design tool in this case taking
a GD X file from DNA to s gene designer
which contains a summary of a number of
constructs that need to be assembled
antha is able to parse these inputs and
give you an estimate of what's going to
come out of it it then is able to
simulate the entire workflow including
all the low-level details for the
connected group of hardware that you're
now to requesting this workflow to be
run against this includes being able to
tell you exactly how long this is going
to take and because it ties into the
inventory system how much is this going
to cost when you actually go into the
details you can find that all the
low-level questions like what's the
plate layout what is the number of
plates you're going to need what are the
consumables that you're going to need
how much do you need to make up of all
of the different inputs for your
workflow have been calculated for you
and again because of the tie into the
inventory management system it knows the
barcodes of these specific objects with
they already exist in say your freezer
having set up your deck appropriately
following the instructions that you know
been provided by antha you can
essentially go from a design of what you
need to pass into a workflow to a robot
starting to actually run your experiment
in what is a grand total of about 45
seconds
now ideally you end up having an
integrated work cell like agenus but the
reality is that many people also have
manual extra operations that they have
to perform as part of their workflow so
an tha's designed to deal with hybrid
workflows where you may have to
physically intervene at different stages
of executing your experiment as such we
have an integrated timeline of what's
taking place on all the different pieces
of equipment and can't assist all the
different transfers have to take place
in the course of it again showing is the
easiest way antha isn't just about
running completely integrated work cells
however the vast majority of people
conduct experiments where they have to
take manual actions as well so antha is
designed to deal with multi-device
multi-element complex workflows where
you do have to physically transfer
objects between different pieces of
equipment and they is able to notify you
both in the web browser or via text
messaging when it's time to take an
action
the net result of all of that demo is
that you've got a robust log of
everything that's been conducted in this
experiment including the physical
objects all the information flow what
specific working practice was performed
at every one of these stages and
ultimately a robust provenance of what
every pieces what was done to produce
every piece of information in your
experimental results at rich data log is
then something that you can readily pay
attention you can readily interpret
using much more complex tools again
beauteous ways to show you that antha
produces a robust integrated log of
everything that took place during the
course of executing an experiment it
also provides a number of different ways
to get access to the data that's
contained within that log here you're
seeing our Jupiter notebooks integration
where you're able to completely in your
web browser have a matlab style analysis
workbook sitting atop the data that's
been collected within an ant the
execution log it's easy for an
organization to develop these sorts of
analysis workbooks in this case you're
seeing one for a multivariate design of
experiment analysis where you're able to
automatically pay attention to all the
input parameters that you've done in an
experiment and compare their potential
effects against the various responses
they've been collected out of the
analysis elements that were integrated
into this workflow
now pulling all that off is quite a
complex system under the hood when
you're actually working with antha these
individual elements are compiling two
standalone software binaries that means
that you have the flexibility of
disseminating a working practice be it a
complex bioinformatics algorithm or just
simply a better way of transforming you
know your bog-standard e coli cell line
either as a close source piece of
software or as open source obviously you
know I do prefer the open source model
but it is important to allow many
different ways of working with this
system to involve at runtime there is a
connected group of laboratory equipment
run by a lab manager this includes a
scheduler dealing with all the low-level
details of when do things move from one
place to another it also includes a
sample tracking in sample management
paying attention to all the objects that
are in flight at this single unit such
as a Janus g3 the work for a manager is
responsible for actually firing up all
these standalone elements that make up
any arbitrary workflow that you're
trying to execute against this connected
group of hardware and it also is able to
if necessary launch elements up in the
cloud because these are wired up over
the network and do not have to be
co-located on the same machine the
device manager itself ultimately is
talking to your various pieces of lab
equipment via our device drivers which
themselves are network services so you
can be talking to the laboratory control
pcs that might be in a device well
connected to a device in another room
assuming your IT department is willing
to let you connect up to the network and
of course all of the data and all of the
events about what is actually producing
these experiments and what's happening
during the course of running them is
being collected into the log service
which under the hood consists of both a
no SQL database a couch TV and also to
special time series record logs so that
you can overlay information from things
like environmental sensors which is
great forensics data where you're trying
to figure out whether any particular
data point is truly a black swan or just
a result of experimental error
I'm more of an organizational basis
there's also a collection of cloud
services including user authentication
dashboard views for things like how many
work sells an organization has access to
device management so that you have an
understanding of how many devices do you
have when were they last maintained and
of course organizational level
experimental data repositories as well
as workflow repositories and element
repositories that means that within an
organization you can share best
practices or for certificate validation
practices this is also where you can
deal with executing much more complex
workflows such as being able to do
things like a genome assembly pipeline
being spun off in much more capable
resourced more much more capably
resourced cloud services everything on a
user interface basis is designed to be
run on touchscreen devices including
iPads and things like Windows 10 surface
devices and is amenable for working with
lab blood still in fact intact now well
that's fun technology let's talk about
the science that this actually lets you
do so at some pace as i mentioned you
know we engineer microorganisms most of
the time for us that's been about how do
we use them for bio manufacturing and
the moment you start talking about all
the complexity attached with you have a
bio manufacturing process it's into the
hundreds of different interacting
factors across environment and of course
with modern synthetic biology techniques
across the genetics as well and it's
impossible to deke involve the two
because actually the outcome of a bio
manufacturing process is a result of
genetics and environment not just the
one so how can you go ahead and on pick
the high-order interactions that are
going on in a system like this well in
our case it's iterative multifactorial
experimentation so we'll start with a
process that we call a factor screen
where you're casting a broad net now
this is an example from trust four years
ago when we were still trying to do this
stuff by hand
believe me you really don't want to be
that guy so even a very narrow question
like how to express an industrial enzyme
is going to require dozens of factors
and truth but in this case we did 15 the
first question being which of those 15
factors matter and having gotten data
you're then able to identify okay we
were looking in the wrong entire part of
his design space we need to move it
having done that we were then able to
start to refine this having identified
that in fact many of those factors were
having no effect luckily for us biology
is filled with these cases where there
are many potential interactions but the
vast majority of them within the
particular part of the problem space
that you're looking at don't matter that
gives more experimental bandwidth to
start to refine and unpick which of
these interactions are truly mattering
and having identified what with key
factors driving the ultimate result
yield of this particular industrial
enzyme meant that we could finally
unpick the true interaction and was
driving this entire system to be clear
this is fundamentally sitting atop
building a model of what might be
occurring in the biological system
determining what observations are going
to tell us the most information then
using antha to physically do the
experiment collect the results with
biology telling us what's going on and
ultimately using that to refine our
model so in terms of actual data it's
not a huge number of experiments that
are required to do this sort of invests
iterative investigation into biology but
the complexity of every single
observation is extremely high so you're
talking about in the course in this case
of improving the manufacturing yield of
an industrial enzyme two hundred fold in
four weeks of lab time with an
additional lab week spent just to
validate the model sampling around it to
be clear each of these different colors
is the results of one week of laboratory
execution and unthinking what drove
those changes well out of those first
experiments that were just testing if
effect occurred you immediately saw a
two factor interaction between
chaperones and time chaperones being a
genetic factor for what machinery was
being transplanted into the organism to
help pro
James folding successfully I'm taking
that to factor interaction though just
as the start of your journey because it
turned out once we had moved to the
right part of the design space there was
in fact a three-factor interaction going
on in this by a manufacturing process
between genetics and environment and
without high dimensional integrated
experimentation there was no other way
to have possibly unpicked this and to be
clear getting these factors right was
the difference between that two hundred
fold yield improvement and about half
that in the average case and if she got
them wrong being on the edge of what we
call a design cliff getting absolutely
nothing out of your value manufacturing
process these design cliffs these
sensitivities to parts of the
environment or parts of genetic space
are all over the place in biology and
are one of the major drivers of why
you'll have a laboratory practice that
works one week and not the next but you
might say that there's a limit to how
complex the system you can deal with you
can obviously can do this in e.coli but
not in much more complex blossoms like
how do you produce a biotherapeutic well
more recent work we've been doing with
merck pharmaceuticals MSD over here in
the UK has been on the development of a
new biomanufacturing platform we're
using antha we were able to conduct an
experimental campaign on over 27
simultaneous factors to be clear that's
looking simultaneously at genetic
modifications to a cell line engine what
we're feeding it and changing the
environmental conditions under which
it's being grown and in the course of 10
weeks of laboratory time we are able to
unpick a four-factor interaction between
genetics and environment that was
driving at enfield yield improvement in
that production process now because
we're building models however we also
had an unfair advantage in a traditional
process you would have been many making
many many variants genetically speaking
and screening for hits which means you
would have gone with this colony right
here unfortunately as that organism
starts to move up into a larger scale
manufacturing environment controlling
temperature becomes extremely difficult
and you wouldn't have been able to take
unpick the fact that that particular
organism was temperature sensitive until
you put it into a large-scale fermenter
and watch your heel drop off in contrast
by being able to conduct these complex
experiments that could allow you to
build models iteratively you could
unpick that by locking in with two
different at genetic attributes you
could build an organism that was robust
against temperature variation and we're
still going to operate successfully once
you move in as a larger scale for
mentors this ability to do model
building is fundamental to ultimately
being able to do design for
manufacturing and to be able to think to
transfer the results of working with a
biological system from one environment
to another it's the exact same principle
that lets you transfer a working
practice like construct assembly or buy
a manufacturing process like making an
antibody conjugated drug now in the
context of just our simple
biomanufacturing investigations you
still have quite a complex process
everything from factor mining to gene
design to gene synthesis to construct
assembly and that itself then is all
being driven by our experimental designs
which factors which genes are we going
to insert into this pathway which genes
are we going to knock down all of that
is ultimately used to build organisms
that we're evaluating in a scaled-down
environment in our case microwell
tighter Wells where we're recognizing
what parts of the transferred context
ultimately large-scale fermentors are we
able to understand it on tick at this
scale it then means rapidly moving into
stirred tank reactors in our case it's a
system from Sartorius calton amber 250
which gives us a context appropriate
environment for understanding the
physical interactions going on with our
organisms and in turn all of the data
coming out of these has to go through an
entire Bank of omics pipelines
everything from looking for various
levels of analytes to sequencing to
understand genetic drift that's
occurring in these organisms and of
course ultimately it's moving up into
stirred tank reactors steel and
confirming that the models are
successfully transferring between these
different
that's at the heart of all of this is
being able to execute these complex
integrated experimental pipelines that
talk to many different pieces of
laboratory equipment and solve all the
scheduling and logistics challenges
across these experimental pipelines that
ultimately means that you can start to
build numerical biology models of what's
going on in these complex systems and of
course feed that back into your
experimental designs now looking into
the future of what is going to become
possible to do with biology we're also
happy to announce that we've started a
lot broad range in collaboration with
Microsoft this includes bringing antha
to the azure cloud service so that
you'll be able to design plan and
execute your experiments purely from
your web browser without having to think
about the IT requirements for it it also
however is it bringing deep learning
technologies to bear so that you can
start to turn a variety of your
currently qualitative data outputs
things like microscopy image sets into
quantitative ones because the heart of
being able to unpick these complex
systems is ultimately being able to
bring the right data out of them so that
you can build informed models of what's
going on with these systems so in
summary antha is for us a ground-up
reimagining of how you engage with
working in theology it's about how you
can talk to all the laboratory equipment
how can you cut through the bottlenecks
that exist in your ability to plan
design and execute the complex
experiments it takes to ultimately gain
complex understanding into systems such
as biology antha is open source you can
get access to it right now on github and
if you're finding out this is something
that's of interest to you I recommend
that you dive in and aunt Elaine org
again I want to thank perkinelmer for
this opportunity to present what we're
doing with antha and their support now
for antha by helping us bring answer to
their Janis g3 platform and I want to
turn it over to any questions you might
have thank you thank you for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box
can be found by clicking on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window try to answer as
many questions as it turn our first
question is what happens if you are
modeling a biological system and miss a
key factor in your model thank you so
enough effective part about multivariate
investigations is that you're
fundamentally building a model of
whether or not the variance that you're
seeing in your data outputs such as the
assay of the product is explained by the
variables that you're taking a look at
in your multivariate model so you
basically are looking is there
unexplained variance as such if you've
missed a major factor there's going to
be a large amount of it if you haven't
well then luckily enough then you're
able to move ahead with a proper model
of what's going on in that system when
you're running these complex campaigns
also with hundreds of runs attached to
them your p values associated with your
conclusions are extremely high so it
gives you an ability to actually
definitively state that the effect that
you're observing is a real one and is
explained by the variables that you have
investigated in your experiments with
design and we'll get people another
moment more questions
if there are no more questions I would
like to once again spank Sean Ward for
his presentation do you have any final
comments for us today we look forward to
seeing what can happen as people are
able to systematically codify transfer
their tacit knowledge and characterize
their fundamental working practices
which is going to give us a collective
foundation with which we can truly
unpick the complexities of biology Sean
a question has come in I'd like to pose
it to you the person says I see and
understand the antha concept from lean
lean six sigma concept the question is
how do we get antha for streamlining
Lean Six Sigma biology research sure so
you can you're correct that there's
quite a few principles of quality by
design baked into antha in essence it's
trying to bring that all the way up the
stream into your early discovery work so
one way you can engage with is with the
open source technology that's already
available there you can also engage with
us directly as we have all of the visual
tools that you've seen presented in this
presentation already available for
access shortly in a cloud-hosted form
and also for enterprise licensing to be
deployed inside of your own organization
thank you I would also like to thank our
sponsor perkinelmer for making today's
educational webcam possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through November 12 2016 you'll
receive an email from laggards for
learning me when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
Ford that announcement to your
colleagues who have missed today's live
event see you next time bye